(Music)
♫ They stood together ♫
♫ under a tree in tall grass ♫
♫ on TV ♫
♫ telling the world ♫
♫ their story ♫
♫ We will be left to wander ♫
♫ and fade away ♫
♫ Soldiers came and took our husbands ♫
♫ at the break of day ♫
♫ We will live on ♫
♫ then fade away ♫
♫ Soldiers came and killed our children ♫
♫ at the break of day ♫
♫ Women of hope ♫
♫ Women of change ♫
♫ Women of war and pain ♫
♫ I believe ♫
♫ I believe the almighty knows each and every one of you ♫
♫ by your name ♫
♫ Women of hope ♫
♫ Women of change ♫
♫ Women of love, joy, no shame ♫
♫ You've got something this little life ♫
♫ can never take away ♫
♫ Running through the darkness of night ♫
♫ with a child by her side ♫
♫ Oh Lord, won't you give them ♫
♫ a shining armor of light ♫
♫ Daybreak brings a sign of new life ♫
♫ with the power to stand ♫
♫ Crossing the border ♫
♫ she said, "You will grow free on this land" ♫
♫ Women of hope ♫
♫ Women of change ♫
♫ Women of war and pain ♫
♫ I can feel your power ♫
♫ in these words she said ♫
♫ If you're feeling helpless ♫
♫ help someone ♫
♫ Nobody really knows ♫
♫ how far they will go ♫
♫ to keep on living ♫
♫ Nobody really knows ♫
♫ how far they will go ♫
♫ to keep on giving ♫
♫ and forgiving ♫
♫ Aung San Suu Kyi ♫
♫ living under house arrest ♫
♫ for her peaceful protest ♫
♫ under house arrest ♫
♫ When her people asked her for a message ♫
♫ she said ♫
♫ If you're feeling helpless ♫
♫ help someone ♫
Now we know the words, let's sing.
♫ If you're feeling helpless ♫
♫ help someone ♫
♫ People of hope ♫
♫ People of change ♫
♫ People of love, joy, no shame ♫
♫ I believe the almighty ♫
♫ knows each and every one of you ♫
♫ by your name ♫
Thank you.
(Applause)